all right um
so we've finished the first unit of the
course
or consumer theory
and we've sort of gotten to the demand
curve
now we're going to move on to the second
unit of the course which is producer
theory and talk about where the supply
curve comes from
now the good news is that a lot of the
tools and skills we developed in the
first few lectures will translate quite
nicely to thinking about the supply
curve and production the bad news is
supply is a lot harder
it's a lot harder fundamentally at the
big picture
because when we did consumer theory
we sort of told you what your income was
we sort of pin we told you income and
prices and then we said okay as you
optimize
with firms they sort of get decide what
their income is they get to decide how
much they produce
and that means we're going to need an
extra whole constraint we're going to
need to model an extra whole larger part
of the process
so let's give me an extra step with
producer theory but a lot of the tools
will be the same
so let's dive in
we're going to start
by talking about just as consumers have
a utility function
producers have a
production function
so the first parallel
is that consumers have a production
function i'm sorry producers have
production function
now here
their goal is not to maximize production
their goal is to maximize profits so as
consumers want to maximize utility
producers want to maximize
maximize profits
which equals revenues minus costs
so the goal of a producer is to maximize
profits
which equals revenues minus costs
and what that's going to mean
is going to mean producing goods as
efficiently as possible
maximizing your profits
we're going to focus for the first few
lectures on the cost part in particular
we're going to focus on maximizing
profits through minimizing costs
and we minimize costs
by producing as efficiently as possible
okay and that's what we'll focus on
uh
in the next few lectures
now what firms can produce comes from
their production function
a potungtion function is of the general
form
q
that's units of goods produced
is a function of the amount of labor
input
and capital input
used by the firm so q
little q let me highlight right here
i will hopefully get this right i never
semester i'm getting it totally right
little q refers to a firm
big q refers to a market
okay we're going to try to keep this
straight so little q means a firm's
production function big q means a market
production function okay so and if i get
that wrong i'm sure you guys will tell
me
okay
so basically
what a production function does is it
converts inputs
which are labor and capital
into output through some function
just like utility function converts
goods into happiness
through some function
it's the same idea here but here we're
producing more tangible
unlike utils output can actually be
measured
so it's the literally it's not some
you know preference mapping it's
literally a technological function
okay you can get your hands around it
more in utility functions literally a
technological function
by which inputs get converted to
an output
now what are um and we call these inputs
the factors of production
okay labor and capital we call the
factors of production
they're the inputs that get used to
produce things
now what are labor and capital labor is
pretty easy labor is
workers okay either number of workers or
hours of work we'll use those
interchangeably but the bottom line is
labor is workers it's you all
okay that's sort of the easy part
capital is harder
capital is machines
land building all the stuff that workers
use to make things
okay so capital's a vaguer concept but
for now think of it as like machines and
buildings
okay the stuff that workers use the cat
the the the stuff that workers use to
produce goods
okay
and outputs are good are the goods and
services that got produced
now when we talk about inputs or factors
of production we're going to talk about
them being variable
or fixed
variable means changeable
fixed means not changeable
okay so variable inputs are inputs that
can be easily changed like hours of work
you can easily work you guys work
different amounts of hours every day you
can easily change the hours that you
work you can pull it all night or
something's due the next day you can
work less if there's something good on
tv okay
harder to fix inputs are those which are
harder to change quickly like the size
of a plant
let's say you're deciding a bigger plant
you can't just instantly do that you
need to it takes a lot of production
process you can see by the giant
production going on as you pass every
day as you walk if you come from east
campus you walk to this building that's
been going to take years to build up
those new the new mit facilities
okay so it's not simple so fixed inputs
are inputs that are hard to change
quickly
and the key distinction we draw we think
about variable fixed is the short run
versus the long run
and these are
the way we define these is that
basically in the short run
some inputs are fixed and some are
variable
in particular we're going to say in the
short run
labor is variable and capital is fixed
so in the short run
you have labor
and then some fixed level of capital k
bar
so in the short run you've got some
building you can't change it but you can
always change how hard people work in
that building
in the long run everything's variable
labor and capital are both variable
okay so there's no k bar capital's
variable in the long run
okay
so the question then is what is the
short in the long run
well there's no good answer to that
intuitively think of the short run as a
matter of days or weeks or months and
the long run is a matter of years or
decades
for your own intuition but technically
the definition is the long run is the
period of time over which all inputs are
variable
okay that's the technical definition the
long run is a period of time over which
all inputs are variable that's our
technical definition so think about how
long it takes to build a plant or make
new machines
okay that's the long run so i'm never
gonna ask you is the short run 8.3 days
or 9.7 days okay there's no right answer
the right answer is technical answer is
the short run is the period of time over
which some inputs are fixed and some are
variable
the long run is the period of time over
which all inputs are variable
okay and it's not a clean distinction
obviously in reality there's a whole
range of inputs
ranging from workers to the gas you pipe
in to use for your thing to the raw
materials you have to buy to the
machines to the buildings
obviously in reality there's a whole
range of variability but once again to
make life easier we're going to shrink
this down to two dimensions labor and
capital labor is going to always be
variable capitals will be fixed in the
short run variable in the long run
okay so that's how we'll boil this down
to make life easy
yeah
can you give an example
buildings machines
the stuff that workers use to make
things
yep
okay so now let's talk about other
questions
with these definitions in mind
let's talk about short run production
let's start by talking about production
in the short run
god
someone needs to invent me some more
indestructible chalk
okay so um
let's start in the short run where
uh where labor is variable get capital's
fixed so in the short runway production
function
q equals f of l
and k bar
okay that's our short run um production
function
okay
now
that means in the short run the firm's
only decision the firm is given a stock
of capital so think of the short run as
you are hired to manage a plant okay and
the plant you don't get to decide if the
plants should bigger or smaller or what
machines it's there your only decision
is how many workers to hire how many
hours of labor to employ and once again
i'll go back and forth to the number of
workers and hours of labor the bottom
line is the amount of labor being
provided
okay
the way you're going to decide that
is you're going to look at what we're
going to call the marginal
product of labor
the marginal product of labor
which is simply
the change in output
for the next unit of labor input
this is very much like a margin utility
of a good once again going back to our
powers of consumer theory the marge
utility of of pizza was the delton
utility for the next unit of pizza the
marginal product of labor is the delta
in the amount produced for the next unit
of labor
okay
and we are going to assume much as we
assume diminishing margin utility we are
going to assume diminishing
marginal product
now this is a little less intuitive than
the michigan mars utility was at least i
hope you found dimension march utility
kind of you two intuitive that the
second slice of pizza be worth less to
you than the first slice of pizza
hopefully found that intuitive
okay
now this less intuitive once again like
with utility it's not saying the next
worker doesn't help
the next worker does help it's just that
the next worker helps less than the
previous worker
okay
now this isn't true everywhere
okay obviously there are tasks where
having two workers together makes both
better and we'll talk about that later
on
but we're gonna we're gonna focus on the
range of production where this is true
think about production functions as
being you know non-monotonic they can go
up and down but we're to focus on the
range of production where this is true
where the next worker is not as
productive
okay because eventually that's going to
be true for every firm
and why is that going to be true
because we're holding capital fixed
the reason eventually workers will get
less productive is because only so many
machines and buildings they can work it
okay the classic example we think is the
example of digging a hole with one
shovel
you've got one worker digging a hole
that she can do a certain amount of
effort
then a second worker comes along
she can add value the first can rest
they can trade off and maybe she's
almost as productive but probably not
quite then the third worker and the
fourth worker by time you have six
workers they're mostly just standing
around because only one shovel
okay now each one's more productive
because they can help you know optimize
the shift and get rests and stuff but
the truth is clearly the six workers
less productive the fifth worker gives
only one shovel
so the poi the key to understanding the
intuition of diminishing marginal
product is to remember that there's a
limited amount of capital it's a fixed
amount of capital
so if there's a given building and
you've got a thousand workers and you
try to shove a thousand in first in
there he's not going to do a whole lot
of good
okay so marginal product of labor comes
from the notion that there's a fixed
amount of capital so each additional
worker
does less and less adds less and less to
the production
okay that's the intuition for
diminishing marginal product of labor
okay
and that's pretty much it for short run
production that's sort of what you got
to know
okay
the more interesting action
comes when we go to long run production
that gets more interesting because now
you have an optimization decision over
labor versus capital
in the short run you just decide how
many workers to hire
in the long run now you're back to the
kind of utility framework we used we had
to trade off pizza and cookies
now you get to trade off workers and
machines now you own the firm you're
gonna own it forever
okay and you get to trade off
you get to think about um
workers versus machines
so now
you're going to have to make a decision
on that so let's actu and that that
decision is going to be driven just as
your decision of how to trade off
cookies and pizza
is driven by utility function your
decision about whether to employ workers
or machines is going to be driven by
your production function
so to make life easy let's start a
production function that looks just like
the utility function we're using
q equals l times k
familiar form before we said how happy
pizza and cookies made you was the
square to pizza times cookies
now we're gonna say how many goods you
can produce
is the square root of capital times
labor
okay
and figure five
one shows you
what that delivers in terms of
graphically
just as to graphically represent utility
we graphed indifference curves
to graphically represent
production we are going to graph
isoquants
okay isoquants are like firm
indifference curves
but once again they're sort of more
tangible a difference curve is this
weird intangible idea of points along
which are indifferent
an isoquant is a tangible thing it's the
combinations of capital labor that
produce the same amount of output
okay so for any given production
function
there's different combinations of
capital labor that produce the same
amount of output
so for example in our example
okay
two units
of capital and two units of labor
produces two units of output
four units of capital and one unit of
labor also produce two units of output
so they would be on the same isoquant
they're just combinations of inputs that
deliver the same level of output
okay
and isoquants all the stuff we learned
about indifference curves apply here
more is better so further out is better
they can't cross
okay uh and they slope downwards
all the set of things we learned about
indifference curves that same set of
intuitions applies here
okay
the difference with production
is it's more plausible to have extreme
cases
okay so let's consider two extreme cases
let's first consider the case of inputs
that are perfectly substitutable so like
a harvard graduate and a beanie baby
okay
perfectly substitutable inputs
okay
those are goods
where the production function will be of
the form
q equals x plus equals l plus k
l plus k
okay that's perfectly substitutable
because you're indifferent between a
universal unit of l they're k they're
perfectly substitutable so you can see
that
in figure 5 2a i do x and y instead of l
and k
but it's the same idea if there's two
inputs x and y
then then with that production function
at perfectly substitutable that would
lead to linear isoquants
perfectly substitutable inputs would
lead to linear isoquants
okay with a slope of minus one because
you're perfectly indifferent between one
or the other
at all levels at any point in time you
are indifferent between one more unit of
x and one more unit of y one mean of
label one unit of capital
okay
at the other extreme
would be perfectly non-substitutable
inputs
inputs where you can't produce
another unit of one more unit without
one of each input
okay that would look like figure 5 2b
we call this a leonteith production
function
a leonty of production function is one
where there's non-substitutable inputs
where you where the production function
is the min
of x and y
that one more unit of y does you no good
unless you also get one more unit of x
so what's an example what's a real world
example of a leonty of production
function what's a good which would have
non-substitutable inputs where you need
at least one of each
yeah
if you have like programmers in
computers
programmers to computers that's a good
one what else yeah
so you need like a right shoe you're
right you in a left shoe that's the
classic example we always use cereal and
cereal boxes stuff like that you know
stuff where you basically need both
shoes is the sort of classic example
okay and that would give you sort of a
leonty of production function
okay
so that's basically those extremes help
you think about what isoquants are and
what they mean
now
continuing our parallel to consumer
theory
what is the slope of the isoquant
okay what is the slope of the isoquant
the slope of the isoquant just as we
call the slope of the indifference curve
the marginal rate of substitution since
we're not very creative in economics we
call the slope of the isoquant the
marginal rate of technical substitution
because it's the same idea but now it's
technical it comes from a technical
production function not from your
preferences
okay so marginal technical substitution
is the slope of the isoquant or delta k
over delta l
okay
and as with indifference curves that
slope varies along
the isoquant so we can see that in
figure five three
okay figure five three is once again
drawn for our production function q
equals square root of k times l
okay
um so let's say for example we start
with one worker and four machines at
point a
okay and now we consider adding a second
worker
well at point a
that second worker is so productive
because diminishing marginal product of
because diminishing marginal products
okay you already got four machines only
one guy to run them like he's not doing
a lot of good so adding a second worker
and two machines helps a lot it's not
perfectly on tf but you can get the the
the intuition
that you're better with your your your
two workers and two machines the same as
one worker and four machines you're not
better off you're the same off you're on
the same isoquant so the marginal rate
of technical substitution is minus two
that is one worker substitutes for two
machines
okay one worker substitutes for two
machines
but now starting from point b moving to
point c
it takes two more workers substitute for
one machine
okay because if you go down one machine
you need a lot more workers to make up
for it so then the mrts falls to minus a
half
so going from a to b
one worker makes up for two machines
going from b to c it takes two workers
to make up for one machine
and that's because of diminishing
marginal products
okay
that's because of diminishing marginal
products
okay indeed
there's a convenient way mathematically
to relate the marginal rate of technical
substitution to marginal products
think of what the mrts is asking
think of what we're asking a lot of
isoquant we're saying what combinations
of capital and labor yield the same
output
that's we're asking
okay
so another way to think about it is what
change in capital
plus an equivalent change in labor
leads to the same level of output
so you can ask
well the change in labor
times the marginal product of a unit of
labor
times the margin productivity labor
plus the change in capital
times the marginal product of a unit of
capital which is the same i didn't
define marge product capital it's the
same idea as marginal product of labor
it's dq dk
okay it's the marginal product of
capital
that equals zero
along an isoquant
think about it along an isoquant
the next union of labor times how
productive that labor is
plus the next unit of capital times how
productive that capital is
equals zero because you're staying on
isoquant so if you're taking away one
unit of labor if this is minus one
and this is plus one
then base it along the isoquant you're
choosing the point where the mpl equals
the mpk
or more generally
if you reorganize this you get the delta
k over delta l
which is the slope
equals
minus mpl over mpk
and that is the mrts
okay
the marginal rate of technical
substitution
is
the negative of the ratio of the
marginal product of labor the marginal
product of capital
once again should look familiar
it's just like the marginal rate of
substitution is the negative of the
margin utility of the good on the x-axis
the margin utility the good and the
y-axis
same idea i derived in a slightly
different way here
but it's the same idea
these and it comes from the notion that
you want to stay that you're staying
constant production as you change labor
and capital along this curve
well mpk over mpl would give you i mean
basically we're defining the marginal
rate tech substitution the way we define
uh
the way we define the marginal rate of
substitution you basically want because
you want it to be downward sloping if
you find that you you'd that'd be
inverse it'd be upward sloping so we're
defined as a downward sloping concept
which is the mars part of the good on
the x axis so the largest product is in
the y axis so it's not invertible it's
not freely invertible
yeah what's the marginal rate of
technical substitution for our leonty
production function
ah great question great question so the
marginal rate of technical substitution
so let's go back to leontyaf
okay the marginal rate of technical
substitution um
actually sort of depends on
it sort of depends on where you are it's
sort of a non-linear marginal technical
substitution
right so basically it's going to very
much depend uh
uh
depend on where you are so basically can
be negative infinity or positive
infinity or zero depending on where you
are on the curve
so we'll actually i don't need more than
that because that this problem may i'm
like anything it could obviously be a
problem set problem so i don't want to
give more answers in that away but it's
certainly it's it's it's going to be uh
it's it's not going to be constant
okay other questions
yeah
marsha if if the curve is just a line
the marginal x substitution would be
constant if for perfectly substitutable
inputs it would be constant that's right
just like the marginal rate of
substitution because if your
indifference curves were linear
okay good questions
okay
so that's production
okay other question about production
okay that's the basics and we went fast
because basically a lot of it's just
parallel to what we differ with consumer
theory
okay
now but i want to talk about two other
aspects of production
that we need to keep in mind
as we move forward
the first and the fourth topic for today
is returns to scale
returns to scale
okay
this is the what returns to scale are
asking is
what happens to production when you
increase all inputs proportionally
so if you double all inputs or triple
all inputs or whatever
cut all inputs by 73
what happens to production so it's not
about k versus l it's about a scale a
scaling up or down of the operation
okay now we know obviously if you
double inputs production will go up
more is better
the question is by how much
so
our baseline we can think about is what
we call a constant returns to scale
production function
that would be one
where f
of 2l 2k
equals two times f of l k
so a constant returns to scale function
means if you double inputs you double
output
if you double inputs you double output
that's a constant returns to scale
production function
but you could also define increasing
returns to scale
where doubling inputs leads to more than
double the output
or decreasing returns to scale
where doubling the inputs leads to less
than double the output
so constant returns to scale means
doubling the inputs leads to double the
output
increasing returns to scale means more
than doubling the inputs
more than doubles the up i'm sorry means
double the inputs more than doubles the
output
decreasing returns to scale means
doubling the inputs less than doubles
the output
okay and that gives you uh that's your
definition of returns to scale
now where could these come from so
increasing returns to scale for example
where could increasingly that's the
world's worst s where could increasing
returns to scale come from
okay so for example one reason for
increasing returns to scale is that
basically as a firm gets bigger it might
learn to specialize so maybe a firm with
two workers and two computers
and you double you have four workers and
four computers and and and then you
could specialize the tasks more and each
worker is more efficient their
specialized task
that could lead to increasing returns to
scale
that's an example of something could
lead to increasing returns to scale
decreasing returns to scale
could come through something like
difficulty of coordination
maybe when i've got two workers or two
computers i can keep an eye on them make
sure they don't slack off with four
workers or four computers there's more
slacking off because i can't keep an eye
on them all the time
and more so with 8 and 16 etc yeah
irs why is
why is
yeah so basically doubling the input so
when i moved to two workers or two
computers to four workers of four
computers i more than double my output
and that's because maybe they specialize
and get more productive
the original
yes
yeah so well it's it's it's one function
f of l it's literally one function it's
little so i'll write it out it's
literally saying doubling my inputs
leads to more than twice what i get with
just without doubling the outputs
okay is that another way to think about
it
yeah
product um being produced or how much
profit how much product we're only we
haven't gotten a product profit yet
we're only talking about quantity
we want to talk about quantity f is f
remember f is the function that
translates uh inputs to q
yeah
are things intrinsically like increased
return to scale functions or decreased
returns well great question so what do
you think
what's what's the right answer
what do we think in reality
i mean like perhaps maybe there could be
ways to shift it or not like like and
going back to the whole example you give
about decreases like if there's more
computers people can start slacking off
and he says like if you set some
parameters or like you know like you
deactivated social media on those
computers that they couldn't go on
facebook when you weren't watching them
you could make them be more productive
well it's a great question let's start
by looking at figure five four
and show some examples of what we think
about like decrease increase returns to
scale so figure five four has some
examples
um
uh of the kind of industries people
think are potentially decreasing
increasing returns to scale
okay so for example we think the
production of tobacco is increasing
returns to scale activity that is you're
kind of farming tobacco you're growing
it you're producing it then if you kind
of double it up
um there's still a certain amount of
land you're working on you can't there's
still sort of a certain amount of crop
you're not gonna bruise twice as much by
having twice as many threshers and
workers
whereas maybe something like prime
producing primary metal
okay you could basically maybe work a
lot more efficiently by having more
machines and more workers together
producing that metal
so what is the right answer
the right answer is we don't know but
the one thing we do know is there can
never be forever increasing returns to
scale and why is that
well at least we used to think this may
be 15 years ago
why is that why can their net what would
happen in an economy if a firm had
forever increasing returns to scale
yeah and monopoly it would own the
economy right because the bigger i got
the more productive i'd get
so i would just eventually grow and own
the whole economy
now actually that may be happening
so maybe it's not as weird as we thought
it was 15 you know uh
maybe you know google the big five have
uh have increased returns to scale
but eventually we think return scale
must decrease we think your scale
production must get so unwieldy
that doubling it means you just can't
manage as effectively
eventually we think return scale must
decrease
that's sort of the one sort of principle
we have
that we don't know
we think generally probably in the life
cycle of firms returns to scale are
probably increasing and then decreasing
but we don't know where it happens and
certainly companies like google and
amazon are showing us that point of
decreasing may happen a lot later than
we
thought okay
but uh and that's because i think what
we didn't account for in our traditional
producer theory is networks
the fact that networks get ever more
productive we always thought about
buildings and workers and the limit how
productive they can get but networks by
bringing in more and more people can get
everyone more productive
but at some point we think these things
have to decrease at least we
traditionally thought so but maybe in 10
years when you know google owns
everything i'll change my tune
okay but that's sort of the one sort of
rule of thumb we have in thinking about
this
okay other questions about that
okay
let's talk about the last topic then
which
is productivity
how this stuff all matters in the real
world
so we're going to come back next lecture
and come back to
maximizing profits and all that stuff
but i want to step aside now and ask why
does this all matter
and to do so let's step way back
to the original dismal scientist
thomas malthus
thomas malthus
in 1798
uh wrote a book
which said which was really pretty
depressing
he said look let's think about how basic
economics works now i didn't do the math
this is pre-math so let's get the basic
intuition
think about the production of food
okay the production of food has two
inputs
labor
and land
there's workers and then they you know
there's machines but they're pretty
simple machines
okay you sort of till the land
okay
and there's land
well in the long run
in the short-run labors of our own
long-run labor's viable but land is
never variable
len is a forever fixed input
there's no long run unless we discover a
new planet
there's no long run over which lands
variable
what that means is that there will be
ever diminishing marginal product of
farming he didn't say it this way but
this was sort of his intuition
that
more and more workers will try to cram
on a given acre of land each initial
worker can only do so much
and eventually the marginal product will
diminishing
okay
the result is that productivity will
fall the marginal product of labor
with each digital worker will be less
and less
and as a result
will starve
because basically all these people
looking for work there's nothing to do
because only a certain amount of land
the only thing to do eventually they'll
starve so malthus actually predicted we
would see cycles of mass starvation
through history
fun guy to have at a party
okay he'd basically say we're gonna get
overpopulated these guys will have
nothing to do because only so much land
they can work on they'll die off will
eventually grow overpopulated with these
cycles of mass starvation
that was his prediction
now
since he wrote that book
world population has increased about a
thousand percent
and yet we're fatter than ever
i'm not saying you know food deprivation
isn't a problem around the world but
certainly the world is much better fed
than it was in 1798
okay
what did malthus missed what did malthus
miss what did he get wrong
yeah
the classic example against it like he
didn't account for innovations he didn't
account for innovation or what we call
productivity
productivity or you can also call it
innovation
and neither have we so far
we have written
production functions of the form q
equals f
of l and k
but in reality the production function
is actually q equals a
times f of l and k
maybe a of t a sub t
and that's a production factor
that basically for a given amount of
labor and capital
as you get more productive you can
produce more things the production
function itself changes
you get more productive over time
okay
in agriculture
how did we do this
well we did it in lots of ways we uh
invented cool new ways to harvest the
crop
tractors we invented fertilizer
chemical fertilizer we invented seed
resistant crops
we invented lots of things that malthus
didn't see coming so as a result even
though the land is just as fixed it was
in malthus's time and someone discovered
a new planet we can farm on
we produce a lot more food because the
factor a the production function itself
has changed
we've become more productive
so productivity
is how is the factor that allows us our
innovation is a factor that allows us
to produce more and more with a given
amount of inputs
so actually food consumption per capita
is rising since 1950
food consumption per person in the world
is up 40 percent
okay
so while we have starvation it's
terrible it's up one side note some of
you may have heard of a very famous um
economist named marcia sen
he's a nobel prize winning economist his
biggest one of his main contributions
was he studied famines
and he said famines are not a
technological problem he said there's
never been in history of famine in a
democracy
no democratic nations ever had a famine
famines are not about technology famines
are about politics and corruption and
the things that get in the way of proper
food distribution
so really we have enough food
okay
the food is there
malthus was wrong
now
this is not just true in agriculture
it's true all over the world let's look
at car production one of the most famous
examples
okay
cars have been around since the late
1800s
okay and they're basically when cars
were first invented they were
essentially craftsmanship someone would
sit down and make a car if you can
believe it
they'd literally make all the parts
they'd make a car or a couple people
together
in the early 1900s henry ford
introduced the idea of mass production
it seems sensible now but it's not the
way they used to do it
a series of workers who reached a
discrete task along the way constructing
a car so no worker did a whole bunch of
the car each worker did a little piece
which massively led to increasing
returns to scale
by specialization
okay
he did that
and basically this was radical at the
time seems obvious to us now
but he cut the price of building a car
more than in half almost overnight and
basically wiped out all his rivals
okay
through the introduction mass production
they might think that's pretty cool that
but you know that's old time story but
it's not over
innovation car production continues
the indian company tada you may have
heard of them they do a lot of mit they
finance a lot of stuff at mit they have
a car called the nano that they produce
for 2 500
okay
it's a tiny car
it's lighter they use extra light
materials
it's smaller because they do things like
putting wheels on the extreme outside of
the car rather than sort of underneath
the car
okay
um and they minimize the parts that are
used to make it easily fixed
interchangeable with other cars so
innovation is going all the time look at
hybrid look at the innovation the fuel
space with hybrid cars and electric cars
and tesla okay innovation is happening
all the time
now what's key about this
besides the fact technically what this
means is that when you're right when you
think about production now we're not
going to talk about this a lot we'll
assume that there's constant production
functions but what that means
technically is when we think about over
time production innovation is a key
factor
but what this means in terms of
all of us sitting in this room
is that productivity innovation is
fundamentally what determines the
standard of living
in a country
our standard of living
is determined by productivity
okay
so basically if you think about us as
workers
we if we're gonna get richer we're gonna
have to make more stuff
okay we have to make more q
or more valuable q
okay
now given our amount of labor that's
either gonna happen through more k
through more capital or through a faster
a
through through faster innovation
so ultimately what determines our
standard of living that is what
determines how much [ __ ] we have for a
given amount of work
is going to be how much we save
and how innovative we are i'm sorry back
how much capital we have and how
innovative we are capital it turns out
is going to come from savings i sort of
cheated there we're going to talk about
that in about
about the maybe 12 lectures from now
we'll talk about where capital comes
from the hint is capital comes from how
much we save and i'll explain why that
is but our channel is turned by how much
capital we have which is a function how
much we save but it's mostly determined
by how innovative we are how productive
we are
how much more we can produce for a given
level of inputs
okay and if you look at if you ask how
does production go up
given an amount of capital and labor we
call that total factor productivity
that is conditioning in all the factors
how much does our productivity go up
now it turns out
we have seen a massive shift in
productivity in the u.s
from
1947
after world war ii
to 1973
productivity growth in the u.s was very
rapid about two and a half percent a
year
what that meant let's look at what that
meant that meant not doing anything else
working just as hard as we were working
we could get two and a half percent more
stuff every year
okay that's made by our standard of
living literally it's saying working the
same 40 hour a week every year we got
two and a half percent more stuff
okay
however from 1973 till the early 1990s
productivity growth growth slowed down
massively down to about one percent a
year
it dropped massively
okay
now
what happened well one thing that
happened is we started saving less
k went down
k is driven by savings we started saving
less we save a lot less than other
nations
but in fact that's not much of it
because even though no one saved much
productivity jumped again in the 19
about from 1995 tonight from 2005
productivity jumped again and went up
again to about two and a half percent a
year
and essentially felt ah this is the it
boom
okay computers were around since the
1970s
and throughout the late 90s early 1990s
people kept saying where's the
productivity game from computers and it
appeared to show up in the mid 1990s
suddenly things got more productive in
the mid 1990s the mid-2000s
okay
productivity rose to about 2.3 percent a
year but
much so of grin productivity has stopped
growing rapidly and is back to about one
and a half percent a year so not as slow
we were as we were so we were so from
1947
47 to 73 we grew about two and a half
percent a year 73 to 95 it was about one
percent a year so that meant with the
same amount of work we only got one
percent more stuff
okay
95 to 05 we went up to about 2.3 percent
we jump back up
but
since 05 we're down at about 1.5 percent
so better than we were at our minimum
but not nearly as high as we were at our
peak
okay
so basically this raises three key
questions yeah
um
uh productivity measure
oh great question so basically we look
at
essentially a way it's roughly speaking
we look at how much stuff gets produced
given how many hours of labor there are
submitted to the economy roughly
speaking how do people work how much
stuff gets made boom that's productivity
nothing super fancy yeah
simple what does tft stand for total
factor productivity that's productivity
uh controlling for capital but the
productivity numbers i'm here are not
total factor productivity they're just
labor productivity allowing capital
change yeah
it would decrease with people save money
but if you say plus isn't you're
spending someone else's life you know
what i i don't want to get i'll go there
we're going to spend a whole lecture on
that so i don't want to go there k
depends on savings just take that as a
given for now and we'll come back to
that we'll spend two lectures on it
actually
okay
now i want to raise three questions
before we go about these facts
okay the first question is
why didn't the i.t revolution
and the computer revolution lead to
longer-lasting productivity gains
why did productivity slow back down
after 2005
okay we don't really know
folks thought that computers would be
the next industrial revolution this is
going to be a this is going to transform
our lives
okay it looks like what it mostly is
transformed how we watch porn
okay
um and basically it looks like in terms
of productivity
it did not actually change things that
much and we don't quite know why but it
is a little bit worrisome that in terms
of the long run that in some sense there
wasn't longer longer lasting gains
from uh in innovation it's the question
my point i'm not answering it
you know there's lots of theories we can
hypothesize all day about what it is i'm
just gonna state the facts and say it's
disappointing um and uh and we need to
figure out what to what to uh what to do
about it
the second question this raises is how
do we spend
increase in productivity what do i mean
by that what i mean by that is
if there's an increase in productivity
of two and a half percent that means we
have two and a half percent more stuff
for the same amount of work
but why do we have to say amount of work
another way to say that is we could work
two and a half percent less and have the
same amount of stuff roughly speaking
okay so i've assumed we work the same
with 25 more stuff but why is that the
right answer
okay and in fact you the us and europe
since world war ii have taken very
different paths in this dimension
in the u.s we've taken all our
productivity and put into cooler stuff
and we work harder than ever
in europe they work less hard i mean
starting jobs in europe has six weeks
vacation
okay nothing gets done in august in
europe
okay they've said and you know and if
you go to europe it's a little bit more
run down
okay not quite as gleaming and cutting
edge as the us in many places
okay basically europe has decided to
take some of that productivity increase
and put it into more leisure time
we've decided to take all that
productivity increase and put it into
better phones and gadgets
okay so the question is who's right we
don't know but the important point is
that's an open question just because
we're productive doesn't mean we should
just consume more stuff there's an open
question of how you spend your
productivity gains
and then there's the final question and
maybe the most important
which is who actually gains her
productivity increases
so
when not from 1947 to 1973 productivity
will have 2.5 percent and virtually
every group in society saw their incomes
go up two and a half percent a year
since 1973 on average productivity
growth have been about 1.5 1.6
on average you average these three
series by 1.6
and average incomes have only gone up
point four percent
so productivity's gone up 1.6 percent
but average income is about 0.4
the difference is the gains have all
gone to the top of the income
distribution
so basically virtually all of the gains
from 1973 until a couple years ago it
started to get better
essentially the bottom 80 of people saw
no improvement of their standard of
living
over a 45-year period
whereas the top 20 saw mass improvement
and even within that the top 1 percent
saw a really massive improvement even
with that the top point 1 and 0.01 et
cetera so that's improvements
so as a result in 1995
the richest 10 of the richest um 10 of
the population earned 15 of the income
today it's close to 25 of the income uh
it's getting even worse since 2009
if you look from 2009 2016. i haven't
have it updated and you look at all the
money that was made in society
on net all of it went to the top one
percent what i mean by that the top 99
were in 2016 the same place they were in
2009 even though the economy had grown
and all the growth went to the top 1
so we're actually in an interesting
world here where productivity gains by
itself may not be enough
if we care about what it does to the
average standard of living and lastly so
a very interesting set of issues around
equity and fairness that we'll spend
time on later in the semester but i want
to raise that issue both that
productivity gains can be spent in
different ways on goods and leisure and
they can be distributed in different
ways and those are the sets of things we
need to be thinking about so we think
about economic policy
okay so let me stop there we'll come
back uh no i guess no section on friday
right it's at mit holiday and we'll come
back on monday and talk more producer
theory